contrôles routiers sont aussi à
l'origine de découvertes de beaucoup
d'infractions notamment des stupéfiants
et trafic d'armes et vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui la recherche des armes
est quand même une de nos priorités
pas plus tard que hier soir ici même sur
ce pont on a interpellé quatre individus
avec des armes dans leur véhicule
donc moi j'en appelle à la
responsabilité déjà les contrôles c'est
papon si vous voulez c'est pas prendre
le bateau ni ne s'est pas pour racketter
les gens comme on l'entend souvent c'est
surtout pour permettre aux usagers de la
route de pouvoir rouler dans de
meilleures conditions dans le respect du
code de la route